У Німеччині бракує кваліфікованих працівників.
Уряд збирається спростити приїзд іноземних спеціалістів.
Тож, де краще влаштуватися на роботу, щоб зарплату не "з’їла" оренда житла?
УНімеччині чотири міста-мільйонника - Берлін, Гамбург, Мюнхен та Кельн.
Тут багато високооплачуваних вакансій.
Але, приміром, у Берліні орендна плата за житло залежновід району
сягає 130-142 відсотків від середньої ціни оренди в країні.
А в Мюнхені - взагалі 170 відсотків.
Це місто з найвищими у Німеччині цінами на нерухомість.
Деякі роботодавці тут навіть доплачують висококваліфікованим спеціалістам,
однак працівники з середнім доходом цього не отримують.
Тож, їм доволі складно утримувати родину.
Шанси знайти хорошу роботу вищі на півдні та заході Німеччини,
ніж на сході та півночі, помітили дослідники.
За даними Інституту німецької економіки, приміром, в містечку Єна в Тюрингії
зі стотисячним населенням кількість вакансій сягає 67 на 100 зареєстрованих безробітних.
Втім, зазвичай, роботодавці повідомляють агентству з працевлаштування лише про половину вакансій.
Це означає, що реально вакансій у цьому містечку на півдні колишньої НДР
більше, ніж людей, які шукають роботу.
Крім того, там низька орендна плата за житло - 81 відсоток від середньонімецькогопоказника.
У другому кварталі цього року найбільше вакансій
було на заході Німеччини - аж 940 тисяч.
При цьому на сході країни - лише 270 тисяч.
За статистикою, німецькі компанії знаходять потрібного співробітника в середньому за 82 дні.
Найбільш високооплачувана професія у Німеччині - лікарі.
Вони заробляють в середньому 84 тисячі євро щороку до вирахування податків.
На другому місці - банківські працівники. 70 тисяч.
На третьому - інженери із щорічним доходом у 67 тисяч євро.
І, що показово, працівники ІТ-сфери - лише на четвертому місці
і мають в середньому 65 тисяч євро на рік.
Незважаючи на те, що столиця Баварії Мюнхен - найдорожче для життя місто в Німеччині,
інші регіони цієї землі поєднують у собі й добре оплачувану роботу, й доступне житло.
Приміром, у заснованому ще римлянами місті Регенсбург та його околицях
вартість оренди житла практично збігається із середнім показником у Німеччині.
При цьому кількість вільних робочих місць на 100 безробітних
більш ніж вдвічі перевищує середньостатистичний рівень і складає 101 вакансію.
У цьому містечку мешкає лише 140 тисяч людей
і є багато великих та малих підприємств, які розробляють нові технології.
Цифрова ера у старовинному місті.